Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
punisher marvel video apparently he's coming back
in the mcu i think we all assumed that he was but
now it seems like we have some confirmation so
i'll explain what's going on because there's a lot
of confusion about what was confirmed and what's
actually happening with the punisher character in
the mcu if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos we're going
to have she-hulk episodes starting really soon
daredevil is coming back again in a much bigger
way than he came back in spider-man no way home
so of course when daredevil does show up
we'll be talking a lot about the marvel
netflix characters just in general all them slowly
coming back through all these different projects
and eventually the daredevil born again series but
the big thing happening this weekend that blew up
that everyone was talking about is that we're
in the middle of convention season so that's
why we're hearing a lot of the actors talk about
all these new marvel phase 5 and marvel phase 6
movies and disney plus series and as part of
daredevil and the netflix characters coming
back in all these marvel projects like kingpin is
another recent one jessica jones is coming back
punisher is coming back in upcoming projects
rosario dawson was specifically talking about
john bernthal's punisher character so here's
the clip of what she said okay so found out
yes i found out yesterday because i hadn't heard
i hadn't heard that announcement but i found out
yesterday that the punisher was happening
again so i feel like it's my second chance
because it was the only one of the shows
that i wasn't in and i love john bernthal
so let's all make it happen collectively guys
be so happy to bring our temple
nice night nurse back for sure
so what she's saying there she's responding to a
fan saying when is night nurse going to come back
in the mcu because she currently said that she
doesn't have a contract with marvel like she's
doing all the star wars ahsoka episodes right
now it's going to be fantastic can't wait to see
all those ahsoka episodes there's a big disney
plus day that they're going to have next month
where they'll release a lot of those disney plus
trailers for like the mandalorian season 3 trailer
we'll hear more about the ahsoka series all of the
marvel series that are coming up so of course i'll
do trailer videos for all that stuff they release
but what she's actually saying is that she heard
the punishers coming back to the mcu and she's
hoping that it becomes an opportunity for her to
have some scenes with john bernthal's punisher
as her claire temple the night nurse character
didn't actually appear during the punisher netflix
series like that was the only big marvel defender
series that she didn't get to be in but after
all the news about the punisher coming back in
the mcu just blew up last night rosario dawson
did the obligatory follow-up post to address
her comments saying the boilerplate i have no idea
will he'll be doing in the mcu when he comes back
like she was saying specifically that she doesn't
know whether he's just coming back in daredevil
born again or if he's gonna get his own punisher
disney plus series also kevin feige and the marvel
snipers were on that like white on rice so like
they definitely have their snipers put on her
first rule of bringing all those netflix marvel
characters back is the actors don't talk about
the marvel netflix characters coming back so if
you see reports from people or websites saying
that she confirmed that there's a punisher reboot
happening at marvel that's not correct that's not
what she was saying yeah she did kind of confirm
punishers coming back in the mcu eventually
but she just doesn't know exactly how they're
going to handle that it's very much like andrew
garfield tobey maguire and daredevil coming back
in spiderman no way home like we heard rumors news
reports about that more than two years ago as of
me posting this video that's how long ago it was
like good example is that andrew garfield actually
revealed and he wasn't lying about this part is
that they all signed their contracts to come back
around december 2019 or so that's when they finish
talks the movie didn't come out till december 2021
that's how early in the process we found out about
them all coming back and when that happened when
the news started breaking like you started to
hear people talk hey i think the daredevil is
coming back i think andrew garfield and toby
were coming back charlie cox andrew garfield
were like we're not coming back we don't know
what you're talking about but that's cool the fans
think that and i did see it and it's a photoshop
i am spider-man in my world but then yesterday
clearly that was not a photoshop what i think is
actually going on with john bernthal coming back
as punisher is that first kevin feige was never
going to recast the character so it was never
an issue of like completely doing a new version
of the character and secondly it was more matter
than waiting for the right time to bring him back
just with the overarching plot of marvel phase
four like what is actually happening in the mcu
in present day so the right time to bring him back
as you all probably assumed is the daredevil born
again episodes there's a lot of stuff that they
want to set up with that series so that's why they
gave them so many episodes so many more episodes
than the other disney plussers they confirmed it
for 18 episodes whereas most marvel disney plus
series only get like six or nine episodes just
so they can make all these contracts early on and
set it up so that they have all the actors and the
characters that they want when they get to those
later episodes that won't start airing episodes
till spring 2024 looking at the marvel phase 5
schedule here punisher could always come back in
cameos before that but i don't think we're gonna
see him until the daredevil series at the earliest
it's the same thing with them doing a thunderbolts
movie like waiting for the right time introducing
a verse of that team when it's the right time
with the plot of marvel phase 4 marvel phase 5
like they're meant to be thunderbolt ross and
val's dark answer to the avengers team and during
avengers end game they basically fractured the
team like a couple of them died r.i.p iron man
and black widow captain america turned into an old
man scarlet witch had a total mental breakdown and
turned into a full-blown multiverse villain for
a hot second so after all that stuff happened in
rapid succession thunderbolt ross kind of pulled
a thanos and said if the avengers won't listen
to the orders that i give them like we already
saw the avengers don't care what he thinks fine
i'll do it myself and thunderbolt ross and val's
version of doing it themselves doing the job of
protecting the world their way their darker way
is the thunderbolts team it implies towards the
end of marvel phase 5 because thunderbolts is like
the last movie in marvel phase 5 that by that time
captain america new world order the thunderbolts
movie the current state of things in the mcu
will be super dark for instance that's why the
daredevil born again series isn't happening till
like right around that same time because during
that we're also supposed to be doing a version
of the mayor kingpin storyline from the comics
like part of kingpin's upcoming story throughout
the echo episodes and then the new daredevil
episodes in the born again series after that
is that he's gonna be running for mayor of new
york city think of how dark things are going to
get in new york city when he becomes mayor it'll
be hardcore that's the kind of environment that
punisher would flourish in the rise of all these
villains like all these bad anti-hero characters
just thinking that they can get away with whatever
they want to and also the punisher character is
kind of an antihero himself with more of a light
side alignment like he is the darkest you could
possibly get as a character and still think of
him as a good person or redeemable in some way and
also it just makes more sense to bring him back
in the daredevil series because he debuted in the
marvel netflix series in daredevil season 2. his
debut was also probably one of the best episodes
of daredevil ever just like their rooftop fight
with him chaining daredevil up they used that
in all the promos it was such a big deal daredevil
will have multiple costumes in the upcoming marvel
projects like the yellow is just the start of that
so it'll probably be the same for all the other
marvel netflix characters but like really good
example though is like jessica jones and luke cage
they don't wear suits like they just wear normal
clothes can we find a yellow shirt that looks
kind of like the old yellow shirt yeah pretty easy
speaking of other marvel netflix characters coming
back even though i don't talk a lot about the
other daredevil characters because like karen
page for instance is a big daredevil and punisher
crossover character most of those core characters
from the original daredevil netflix series
are all coming back like eldon henson's foggy
nelson i believe is supposed to come back and i
believe karen page is also coming back as well
i don't know if they'll be back in the echo series
they might be but they'll definitely be back in
daredevil born again episodes part of the idea
is that i think that daredevil will just be in
most of the echo episodes with kingpin they won't
be in like every single episode but they'll be in
most of them and it's sort of like them easing
back into the marvel netflix characters like
we'll give you a little taste in spiderman no way
home and then obviously kingpin in the hawkeye
series just a little bit then a little bit more
during the she-hulk series and then even more
proportionally in the echo episodes next year then
obviously them in every single episode during the
daredevil born again series you also probably
noticed that marvel put all the old punisher
episodes on disney plus along with all the other
marvel netflix series like all the daredevil
episodes luke cage episodes jessica jones even
the iron fist episodes yes even you iron fist
all those are on disney plus now and they just
sort of get people ready for the characters coming
back in a bigger way like oh yeah by the way we're
bringing these characters back why don't you go
back and you watch all these if you skip some
of them so everybody post all your predictions
about john bernthal coming back in the daredevil
born again series what do you think they're going
to do with the character in the future right now
i'm just expecting cameos like smaller appearances
kind of like the way they used him in daredevil
season 2. i'm not expecting them to give him like
his own solo series during marvel phase 7 or
anything like that i don't think that they're
quite to that point yet but like i said kevin
feige is never going to recast the character
like john bernthal is the punisher it was the
same thing with him bringing back a version of
willem dafoe's green goblin like he said that when
there was the chance that they got the spider-man
characters back like way back in captain america
civil war when he knew that it'd be possible to
do some of these spider-man characters together he
said that he at no point ever considered recasting
the green goblin character like he said he always
felt like it was willem dafoe it's the same thing
with a lot of these marvel netflix characters so
like even though we don't know about luke cage
coming back yet he's not going to recast luke
cage like mike coulter will always be luke cage
so they're just waiting for him to be available
to come back that's why kristin ritter is coming
back as jessica jones we know more about her
coming back like she is confirmed to come back
but big reminder my she-hulk episodes are going to
start in a couple weeks make sure you enable orbs
for my channel so you don't miss those there'll
be a lot of other big series starting that i'll
be doing episode videos for but i'll talk about
those in my separate trailer videos they even just
dropped a brand new sheethole trailer so i'll do a
video for that next everyone click here for my new
daredevil versus she-hulk trailer video and click
here for that really cool ghost rider she hook
easter egg thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!